get from The Slap
oh actually I do got some heat I didn't
know we gonna come and then I didn't
know I was coming [ __ ] we spoke last
night on the phone stop and I forgot
yeah but you knew you just forgot don't
say that you didn't know
the intention is different when you
didn't notice because it was not implied
or not I just said oh yeah I'm coming
and no yeah I should have used I didn't
remember yeah exactly that's it that's
what I'm saying all this tension bro
it's not tension calm down man hold up
hey audience you guys decide does that
sound like Texas Jesus [ __ ] Christ
you such a [ __ ] sometimes getting
getting to getting the audience involved
is always a good idea oh wait a minute
we could we could talk about some [ __ ]
we could talk about some [ __ ] I got a
question for you okay how come whenever
I punch you like that you [ __ ] don't you
do that [ __ ] again if you can't say
you're not gonna do something you
already did
I'm not going to punch High by the arm
I just did bro I thought you're gonna do
that [ __ ] again I'm like yo we're gonna
have a problem the first stop for an
example is acceptable don't do that [ __ ]
again
see but when a girl does it you don't
say [ __ ] when a girl does what yeah
punch you with [ __ ] a girl you don't
even what girl punch me peep game I was
on the internet and I was just looking
at [ __ ] like and then A video popped up
him and some girl right and then I start
the video because I want to know what
the [ __ ] it's about it's and then he
started talking about relationship and
[ __ ] but I swear to God not but
30 seconds now but 30 seconds in the
video the girl punches him and then
later on like five seconds after she
goes like that and you don't say [ __ ]
pause the video close the [ __ ] video
yo yo [ __ ] video
I don't remember what a [ __ ] name is
Brittany yeah what's he do I'll pull it
up because I know exactly yeah watch the
beginning of the video I was I saw that
[ __ ] I was like hey everyone that's how
I do my podcast that's my brand that's a
weird way to talk about loneliness oh
okay I could never you wanna know why
you know why I don't give a [ __ ] hold on
hold it actually doesn't matter you
ready to see why go ahead why okay okay
[ __ ] because you feel this way now I
don't care hold up after I show you this
video you understand why I gave her okay
you ready Cool okay cool because I was
like [ __ ] I go like this and I was even
explaining the [ __ ] and this
[ __ ] like don't ever do that
[ __ ] again
ready let's girls hold on wait Britney's
and Karen's hit him okay and it's okay
okay I'm the one that's down with white
girls but he's the one letting white
girls hit him and that's not a problem
yes I want to see this okay
Stephen this is for you I wanted my hair
okay this is how you guys get quality in
life okay ready three two one
she loved that [ __ ] she loved that [ __ ]
that that's not no no she wanted that
mm-hmm that's not a pass cause she
wanted that she consented to that no
we're not doing this oh no hold up hold
up hold up I can she consented to let me
hit him I said you got to get one on me
no no okay you oh hold on
look at the camera
that's why you said that play the clip
[ __ ] no [ __ ]
[ __ ] congratulations I never told
anyone this my hand still feels
different
ah
come on black lives matter
get another one
okay ready round one
[Music]
you win oh you understood you understand
like like I have time to play I get it
for the audience I I rubbed it out you
know what I'm saying
I haven't washed my hand in a week [ __ ]
which is kind of disgusting but still
okay so I just want you to under you
right
no I don't like it when anybody does
that and I've told stories on good women
and they should still go like no that's
not one hold up that was two strikes
hold up hold up hold up hold up you
friend like that too you did this to me
many times I say nothing yeah but you
know what the [ __ ] that is there's oh
well wait a minute man you want to get
the right to be able to
put hands on me what the [ __ ] are you
saying [ __ ] yeah is that what you want
are you stupid or are you high both
[ __ ] what's up yeah you get what's up
okay yeah I ain't no [ __ ] stranger
that's fine
I don't like being hit like that I don't
like being either and you you know that
and you do that all the time watch
yourself what hold on you do that all
the time I do this it's very different
than doing this oh wait okay we shall
see okay hold on you know what you do on
camera and I never say anything about it
you push me
you know why I do that why because you
started pushing me yeah the only reason
I start doing that is because you do it
yeah the only the reason I do this is
because you're always like that that's
the I reciprocate I match energy I don't
believe in astrology but I match
[ __ ] energy so if I do some
[ __ ] it's because that's the same energy
that comes from you hold up do you think
the difference be like yo yo you don't
okay
you don't okay watch stand stand next go
ahead stand next so we talk and you're
like this with your elbow it's not just
it's not this okay you down play it I
didn't know this was like something you
didn't like no it's not something I
don't like I don't even think it was
broken
you're getting this wrong you're getting
this wrong it's not something I don't
like but if you do this and this I'm
gonna turn around to give an example and
like it's like if I did this boom see
that I'm like that's because I don't do
the same thing okay it's not you can
feel like you say to me it's not the
same thing then I said okay okay so if
you feel like it's not the same thing
yes and I feel like the same thing we're
just agree to disagree because there's
nothing out there's nothing else I can
see I'm not saying okay because okay let
it be like no it's like okay yeah you
explain yourself I explain myself
there's nothing I can furthermore right
to and there's that you're gonna let
white girls hit you that's fine
hey only if I get to slap him first
which don't even lie that's a good deal
tell the truth tell us it is a good deal
it's a good deal because UAC means no
random girls that's fine yeah don't even
play that that's fine but if you want to
get smacked up yeah we can do it
it would have been weird if I did let
her do that
after I smacked her in the face no if
she wanted it [ __ ] you you want me to
smack you hold up no no hold on if you
want me you what hold on wait wait a
minute okay did you propose her I'm
gonna smack the [ __ ] out of you
and she said yes yeah look to me that's
the thing that happens yeah well okay
okay okay context what happened was she
smacked destiny
then it's not equal if she hits you
what you mean because she Smacks the
truth is I inserted myself in that
situation just so I could snack
I'm being honest I can't laugh my whole
life
the truth is I had nothing I just really
wanted to smack a white girl and she
said yeah
you know what
I'm gonna let this one
oh that's a pretty good idea
I'ma let this one go I'm like okay yeah
okay so the whole thing about
um I've never had an issue with people
putting their hands on me like yo stop
this I've never had I just this is like
childhood thing you know how you have
PTSD about certain random things yeah
for me absolutely for me this is it
yeah and and that's it I mean hold up
there's this and here's the one that's
even worse than that that drives me
[ __ ] No don't touch my face I'm not
gonna do that okay I I don't even play
that because
I think we have the same pts as a face
no no you mean someone might do that to
you guys
preach you touch me like it's not the
same though we agree it's not the same
right yeah that's fine I just I just got
it okay
we all got our little things that and so
that's why I'm like yeah you know what I
mean if you want to push me that's fine
if you want that a [ __ ] [ __ ] get out
the way hey you hey [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying you kind of young so when you
be doing this I'd be like this I'm kind
of yo
I'm here okay
I ain't a small [ __ ] but I feel it yeah
but it's cool I had no friends what do
you mean like [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
it will you do that [ __ ] I got no
problem cause you did that [ __ ] you
pushed me in that [ __ ] thing the
[ __ ] thing fell off yeah yeah but
you've also pushed me off screen a few
times you want to say which one came
first I'd be it's hard to tell the
chicken or the egg you know what I'm
saying whoa whoa whatever that was the
egg
okay was it yeah reptiles they were not
chickens but they were eggs no you
didn't just break them hey I said what I
said yeah you broke down evolution in
two seconds yeah okay smart like that I
admitted that they thought what was the
question the chicken or the egg the egg
came first yeah right not chicken then
after that it evolved if you come to me
you say your ABBA is kind of
unreasonable that you do this but you're
not done with this I'd be like sure I
don't disagree but it's my thing
that's my thing and maybe the way that
you play fight with your homies and your
people you guys touch each other you
don't Smack the behind the head
I see [ __ ] who do that to each other
don't ever smack me behind the head and
you agree right
you know what I'm talking about
right yeah we all got our things between
people yeah that's a fight right that's
a fight we're gonna be cool after wow
like this they're putting I never
touched somebody's face but I know
people who do that among friends anybody
got they think and Independence also the
resolution that got with you you know I
mean yeah like in the context but if I
don't know you like that I don't care
even if you my girl if you if you're
doing this we gonna have a problem
there's just certain things I just don't
like being touched in certain ways but
that's for my childhood that's where I
come from but the thing is like you have
to uh
you have to be a
like go for it you have to be mature
enough in a relationship and I'm talking
about any kind of relationship friends
or whatever I want to assert that in the
beginning like your boundaries are very
important it's something that we don't
do we do not do that like but because
it's not something that we just okay
here's are the boundaries like we don't
do that that's not really organic and I
get that but it's something that we have
to force yourself to do whether in a
relationship or with like just not to
cause problems when someone tells you
not to do some [ __ ]
don't do it well yeah don't do it but
also don't [ __ ] take it back yeah
there's some people that's going to act
a certain way okay you acting up hey
just take it yeah I'm sorry yeah keep
pushing as a person that's been
um
infringed yeah
if the person says sorry don't [ __ ]
dwell on that [ __ ] for like 20 to 48
hours like it's it's don't make them
apologize sorry sorry because I really
don't like that [ __ ] I said sorry yeah
cause you hey you know what the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] and I'll hit you again [ __ ]
sometimes you be like yo you trying to
punk me now to apologize right now
you're after you're acting like a whole
ass cop
you know where you're supposed to
de-escalate a situation but you don't do
that you make it bigger yeah don't be a
cop all right
blue lives matter man leave them alone
bro
yeah I'm protected us only if I could
slap
Hey listen if there's a cop watching who
wouldn't mind a slant from priest on
camera listen you might be getting paid
okay
but Jokes Aside Jokes Aside
yeah
all right hold up would you do that oh
[ __ ] okay they get to hit you back hit
me back okay would y'all both get one
punch yeah he he he punched me oh my God
he punches me first yo that's content he
punches me first yeah okay he punches me
further we can't do punch oh my God okay
slap slap because I don't know because
somebody can actually get hurt slap slap
and then whoa
okay I got one grand for any cop Who's
down to do a slap on with preach what
smack one smack each and then we call it
dips you get to wear your uniform who
goes first that's a fetish who go first
no he goes first okay
he goes first yeah Hey listen yo listen
if this video gets to 40 000 likes and
we and we get a cop and we get a copy
volunteers if it gets the 40 000 likes
everything I have a paramedic I have a
paramedic on set you know what I'm
saying against the 40 000 within an hour
what are you talking about but what you
said in regards to
um
well you said in regards to relations
like it's facts it's like sometimes in
the moment the person might feel really
respected or feel some type of way just
talk it out afterwards and everyone's
common then you just men defenses but
it's not that deep
it's not that deep and also like we're
on camera so everything is being played
up for extra reactions yeah so you might
sound extra offended or whatever like
the way you guys see us on camera
understand it's exaggeration that's what
comedy is we're just exaggerating
certain reactions to certain things and
so it might be some negative truth but
the degree yeah maybe we exaggerate
we'll do we exaggerating I mean on
camera it's us but it's us turned up oh
see so you exaggerate yeah wow yeah when
I say oh I exaggerated listen he's gonna
listen listen
after you slap a white girl you mess
with that hand and [ __ ] different
the semen extra white you feel me we're
gonna cut that out I'm not cutting
nothing out yeah I'm not gonna cut
nothing out now do it consensually okay
if you got to do it no this is wrong
what's wrong with that it's wrong listen
white women if you love your black
boyfriend because I know a lot of you
watching interracial relationships
because that's how y'all wrote
bro if you love him let him smack you
bro this is not gonna fly well it's not
gonna fly
I bet I bet you it will you get into
smacking a girl
yeah no that's not gonna no no no no no
no no a black man
getting to the fact that he was able to
get Justice after years of Oppression
from the white woman so you need to put
it like that no no I just did no yeah I
know you just did yeah we're good
absolutely I hit her with that civil
rights right
Civil Right civil rights right
you know I mean give her that handle
right in that fart left
every finger
I swear to God you guys thought hitting
one million subscribers was a highlight
this is the greatest highlight of my
YouTube
I think it's got to be up there top
three moments
top three moments that's for me that's
me okay but anyways anything else you
want to say I'm letting this there go
all right let us know what you guys
think about in the comment section below